Who am I there are people believe that
this world is fairing it
it's all lollipops and rainbows
we don't do lollipops and rainbows we
know those are pretty colors that just
hide what the world really is black and
white soon they will shout save us
whisper
we convinced ourselves that they were
gone but they were just hibernating the
game everybody oh please
coordinated simultaneous attacks at the
homes of Tulsa PD until the cops hide
their faces and now the bad guys don't
know where they live and who doesn't
want a secret identity
[Applause]
people who wear masks are dangerous we
should be scared of them because they're
hiding something
Laurie Blake FBI you know you can tell
the difference between a masked cop and
a vigilante no me neither
near the fast and insidious conspiracy
at play towards you fire a Twix phone
[Music]
who are you maybe yeah dr. Menon he
lives on [__] Mars curse too much
[Music]
oh [__]
nothing
so they just forgot
[Music]
you